anyways
[Music]
um
closer
together
yes
foreign
thank you
today
happens
again
foreign
[Music]
good evening welcome to the table
everybody
my name is Maggie Tilford and it is my
privilege to welcome you here
wherever you're coming from whatever
mode you're in and whatever you may be
carrying with you tonight
it is really an honor to have you join
us for worship and we hope this can be a
safe space to show up with all of you
and whatever that looks like and
whatever that means all of you is
welcome in this space
um we like to start out with a few just
details announcements and um touch
points just so you know what's going on
in our community and any opportunities
for connection that um we have for you
so the first one tonight is actually if
you are newer to the table or you've
been around for a while and you're just
wanting more information or looking on
okay how do I get more involved or what
does that look like we actually have a
welcome to the table class coming up two
Sundays from tonight on August 27th and
it will be before church so we're trying
to find a slot that's the most
convenient for people since they're
already headed out this way it would
start at three o'clock and it'll be an
hour and a half so from 3 to 4 30 on
August 27th you can sign up for that by
going out into that little hallway
there's a tiny table with a box on it
and it has a QR code and if you just
snap that QR code it will send you to a
list of links and you can sign up for
the welcome to the table class there it
is not a commitment to like sign in as a
member it really can be just
informational if you're just wanting
more details about who we are how we got
started and what we're about here
um my second announcement also can be
accessed through that same QR code on
that little table it is
um we are in contact with a lgbtq
affirming Counseling Group in McKinney
Texas and they
um actually I wrote the name down
because I'm having trouble sharp
Wellness is the name of the group but
they are offering
um sort of like a workshop for family
members and Friends of lgbtq members and
it's to get more information for
instance if you're an uncle and you have
a teen in your family that just recently
came out as pansexual and you're
wondering what does that mean and I'm
not exactly sure but I don't want to ask
the wrong question or say the wrong
thing that might be offensive and you
just want a place where you can talk
openly get more information in a safe
space from someone who knows what
they're talking about this would be a
perfect class for you or if you're a
grandparent or a mom or just a good
friend of you know an lgbtq member and
you want to know how to be there for
them and how how to be a loving presence
in their life this is for you um and so
that same QR code on that table is there
will be a link
um and it's I think the link is called
under the queer umbrella and you would
click on that and tell us if that's
something you would be interested in
signing up for because before we
schedule it we kind of want to just take
a pull of our community and say would
this be helpful would you know are there
enough people here that would benefit
from a class like that
um but we would hold it here at the
table and that Counseling group would
come here and put on the workshop so
anyways it's something we're interested
in offering but kind of want to see if
that's something that would appeal to
you guys
um and lastly
um I get to serve as part of the
leadership team for our youth Meetup and
as of tonight we are officially back to
our weekly meetings we took our summer
July Hiatus so it's been like six weeks
since we've been together and we're just
getting the word out but specifically if
you have a teen or you are a teen we
have two different group me
um what do you call those groups
on GroupMe that we send out reminders to
on a weekly basis saying hey guys we're
meeting tonight or if there's an extra
event hey we're going to do such and
such you know put this on your calendars
so
um please please myself or Marissa
Martinez in the back is standing
um in the pink shirt or rose-colored
shirt Bermuda but either of us could get
you access to that group me and invite
you so that you can have all the
information
that with a lot of details so I wouldn't
I'm going to transition us now into a
more worshipful Spirit here
um and I'd like to pray over us I came
across a quote the other day from this
book and wanted to read it
um it stood out to me and
um it's by Theresa of Avila and it says
prayer is nothing else than being on
terms of Friendship with God
isn't that so good
um I thought of you Johnny Johnny been
interested in offering a prayer class
for a while and I knew that one would
hit the spot with her but
um in the spirit of Friendship with God
would you guys bow your heads and let me
pray for our time tonight
God we thank you so much
um
just for this this Breath Right Here In
This Moment
God we breathe in
and release it letting go of the things
that we cannot control
being honest about the things that are
on our minds and our hearts before you
and asking you to be part of it all
to come and walk with us through it
Lord we invite you into this space and
into our lives
because we know that you're good we know
that you're loving and that we can trust
you
and I ask that you'd give us a greater
glimpse of who you are tonight it's in
your name that we pray
amen
Thanks Max
um if you guys want to go ahead and
stand with us we're going to get started
with some music and we're starting with
the song Heavy we've done it before but
if if this is your first time to hear it
at the end of the song
it's a great moment for you to get
involved
um and put your hands together clap it
out at the end so if you feel up for it
I love any opportunities that we have to
engage all of our senses and all of who
we are and I just feel like that helps
us connect with this present moment and
bring our full selves to the table so to
speak so um anyways you kiddos anybody
else in the room if y'all want to clap
with us at the very end through the
acapella part it's just a fun way to
wrap up the song all right
um
[Music]
thank you
if you're lost
go on and figure out why
take a trip to the dark side go on and
have a good cry cause we're all lonely
but we're all on me together
[Music]
I want to see your sadness I want to
share your sins I want to plead your
blood and I want to be led in don't you
just don't we
together
[Music]
heavy
what's heavy behind
he was heavy
[Music]
your face
hey
did you lose
[Music]
heavy
behind
[Music]
what's heavy behind
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
what's heavy behind
please
leave what's heavy
what's heavy behind
[Music]
all right kids y'all are released to go
to your classes
thanks to all of our kids ministry
workers who are helping them out this
week and loving on those kids we
appreciate you guys
[Music]
please
I got the
privilege I told you guys last week to
serve with our kids ministry at samarama
and these teachers are such a gift to us
and I'm so grateful for them
[Music]
we're gonna go ahead and enter into the
prayers of the people so if you guys
would just read this prayer out loud
with me and then we'll hold space for
each of us to lift up a name or a
situation that's on your heart and if
you're online feel free to leave that in
the comments and we just want to hold
space for each other for the hard things
that we're carrying and just like we
were just singing we come in here
sometimes very heavy and this is an
opportunity to name some of that and and
let some of it go let other people
shoulder that burden with you and trust
that God Is With Us in those in those
hard places in those heavy places
Jesus for this city of Sachse Texas and
for every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you for the Good
Earth that you have given us and the
wisdom and the will to conserve it we
pray to you for the old and the sick for
the Widow and the orphan for the injured
and suffering we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and the destitute for
prisoners and captives and all who
remember and care for them we pray to
you
for the vulnerable the marginalized and
those unjustly targeted for their gender
sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you for those
experiencing loss of loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you
Lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us so we lift these names and
situations up to you
[Music]
foreign
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts we pray to you
that they may have liked life healing
and hope peace and a deep sense of your
presence and
[Music]
thank you
peace bring it all to peace
the storm surrounding me let it break
at your name
[Music]
or call the sea to still
the Raging me it is still every
way
at your name
Jesus Jesus
you make the darkness tremble
your silence fear
Jesus
you make the darkness tremble
Jesus Jesus
[Music]
is
breathe call these bones to live call
these lungs to sing once again
I will Praise
Jesus Jesus
make the darkness tremble Jesus Jesus
your silence fear
Jesus Jesus
you make the darkness tremble Jesus
Jesus
silence fear
Jesus Jesus
you make the darkness tremble Jesus
Jesus
[Music]
your name is a light that the Shadows
can't deny your name cannot be
overcome
your name is
[Music]
[Applause]
your name is a light that the Shadows
can't deny your name
is
[Music]
[Applause]
delay and the Shadows
[Music]
Jesus Jesus
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
Jesus Jesus
you make the darkness tremble Jesus
Jesus
silence fear
Jesus Jesus
you make the darkness tremble
[Music]
is so good
God is so good
he's so good to me
please
he cares for me
he cares for me he
cares for me
he's so good to me
[Music]
foreign
God is so good
[Music]
and he's so good
he's so good
to me just your voices
[Music]
God
is so good
good he's so good too
[Music]
thank you God for who you are in our
lives
that your present
that you love us
and that you call us forward
[Music]
and I pray that that light
the love of Jesus
would Pierce through whatever Darkness
we're facing this week
that we would look for the light
that we would bring it with us into
every situation to our workplaces into
our homes into our friendships
[Music]
God would we bring your light and your
life with us
we love you and thank you for this time
together in Jesus name
amen
[Music]
you guys can go ahead and greet the
people around you make them feel at home
and then Brett will get us started on
our message
so good to be with you all can we get
those lights up
um it's looking real dark
you all can see me I can't see you
um well welcome welcome I really am I'm
so grateful to be with you and I want to
welcome all of you and as always that
includes those joining us online
uh you are not forgotten our online
community
and as always a huge thank you to James
Townsend it's Faithfully every week on
that uh on online just chiming in
leaving comments you know just he's
always there so thank you James and uh
and anyone else who's who's joined us so
um and also I want to mention anyone
who's new
um thank you for being here I know it
can it can be a process coming through
those doors plugging in meeting people
all a little nerve-wracking
um so just know um that you are wanted
and welcome here where we've really um
strive to be you know not a uh us for
and no more kind of church but um one
that just extends the the radical
hospitality and welcome of Jesus so
um yeah so we are in um let's see part
two
in our series titled the book of James
and uh last week we were um talking
about uh suffering how Christ calls us
um not to I actually heard later I was
talking with um Charles Kaiser who if
you were here last week you remember he
was he's our church planning coach and
he was sitting there in the back row and
uh afterwards he said um the term he
uses when we God calls us to um go
through suffering but we really want to
avoid it but kind of use religious
things to kind of avoid it is um he
calls it spiritual bypassing
um like sometimes what you need to get
do is get really honest with yourself
but we'd rather I don't know we'll do
something else you know what I mean it's
I think it's time to listen to another
Christian podcast that's really what I
need to do right now just more
information for sure I think more
information will solve all my problems
you know of course I have nothing
against Christian podcasts but you can
see where we use things you know to kind
of spiritual bypass so that was kind of
the message last week was along those
lines um next week we'll be um talking
about faith and works and uh some stuff
there's plenty of theological uh stuff
going on in James about that topic um
but this week uh the title my message is
desire and attack
desire and attachment if you've been
around the table for a while you you'll
notice like desire is kind of a theme
I'll like loop back to you partly
because the scriptures live back to it
um but also I think it's a really
relevant topic but one that's often kind
of lost
um lost on us as westerners so um we
actually have two passages tonight
because the way we're going through the
Book of James isn't like line by line
verse by verse instead I'm just kind of
hitting on like themes so you'll notice
we're in like chapter one and chapter
four
um because they're well you'll be able
to hear the similarities in these
passages
so all right this first one James
chapter one uh verses 13 and 14.
when tempted no one should say God is
tempting me for God cannot be tempted by
evil nor does he tempt anyone
but each person is tempted when they are
dragged away that's quite an image isn't
it
I mean that's not gentle
you know dragged Away by what
by their own evil desire and enticed
then after desire has conceived it gives
birth to sin and sin when it is full
grown gives birth to death
all right then let's go to um James
Chapter 4 verses one through two what
causes fights and quarrels among you
don't they come from your desires that
battle within you you desire but do not
have so you kill you covet but cannot
get what you want so you quarrel and
fight
again two very intense passages now what
kind of strikes me
in these two are
obviously there's a lot of similarities
it's actually the difference did you
hear the way that chapter 4 has a
missing word like a very key word for us
uh so let me read just verse 14 again so
this is chapter one but each person is
tempted when they're dragged Away by
their own evil desire and enticed here's
chapter four what causes fights and
quarrels among you don't they come from
your desires that battle within you
are you catching the the missing it's
evil
evil right so chapter one's your own
evil desires as opposed to just your
desires
and this is I think um
probably chapter four would be the more
radical verse for us
because I mean I this would be I don't
know I guess like a super boring sermon
if I was like you know evil desires are
evil and they're bad so don't do them
don't do that you know be like you know
no kidding it sort of like a story about
Sin like so sin is bad so don't do it
you know it's like boom very
enlightening you know
um so I think you know chapter one evil
desires of course
I mean we could think I mean what's like
an evil desire like murder you know
again very boring Thurman like do not
murder don't murder people come on we
can't we can't do that we just can't you
know um it's like well okay obviously
um but chapter four chapter four like
wait
your your desires don't they come from
your desires that battle within you like
what
I thought
desires kind of good or what's the
what's the deal here
and um I think you know this idea that
actually just simply
um or maybe the way I phrase it is like
that potentially desire just in and of
itself
could be kind of problematic that's like
a idea for us as westerners uh partly
because
I mean we live just in the most uh I
mean prosperous
age everywhere like maybe previous
generations couldn't really have so many
of their desires that they sort of
naturally limited them you know and was
like well got no money so uh let's you
know let's just keep our desires very
minimal this we can be happy
um whereas now it's like you get you
know you get some extra cash and it's
like oh the opportunities are endless
you know and uh of course we have this
is kind of one thing that's interesting
about our economic system is the way it
sort of um doesn't just fulfill our
desires you know although uh capitalism
does an amazing job of that my goodness
we have you know you like ice cream
great we don't just have like chocolate
vanilla strawberry you know oh no we
have a thousand and one flavors what was
that Baskin Robbins thing was that a
basket where they have I mean it's not a
thousand but it's like 33 33 different
flavors of ice cream
I mean Mike I just imagined the person
who just goes in there just like no
nothing here I want okay I'm going to
the next place you know it's like oh my
gosh we got a sickness you know
um right it's the pro it's so it's not
just that we can fulfill desire it's the
way our even the kind of system in which
we live it um proliferates the desire
it's just the endless I mean you the way
my uh son I was um we were driving today
from a soccer game and he mentioned he I
don't even remember the topic we were on
but somehow he gave this analogy he said
you know what life is like it's like
your mountain climber and you climb you
like spend all your you know all this
time I climb to the top of one mountain
and then you get there finally
and then you look across the landscape
and what do you see
another
Mountain
and you think ah I've got to climb that
mountain
you know and then of course what happens
get to the top of that mountain and then
what do you do
I gotta find that you know it's just
like oh okay uh right the thing that I
thought would fulfill me and would be
like yes finally I'll forever be happy
you know and what do we find that desire
can sort of be this
um this endless well but of course this
is really um it's tough for us because
in the west like our whole kind of
Western vision of the good life is
precisely the power to get what you want
what you desire you know and of course
the universe is sort of like the worst
of lives you know to not be able to get
what you oh my gosh you're just doomed
you know doomed to a life of
um nothingness yeah
um it's a really yeah it's a tricky
tricky thing
um and of course marketing commercials
don't help
um comparison doesn't help I mean how
quickly or like we're content
until we see someone we're like they
have that fancy you know like they
you're like hey come see my new house
you know and just like it's beautiful
you know that's what you do on the
inside you know on the outside you're
like oh
you know
um
right because we're just not it's so
hard it's so hard um
to be content
so so hard now
um I guess the push back to this would
be like well
again isn't desire good like clearly
evil desires are evil but like can't
desire be good what if what if I don't
know like I'm uh I'm thirsty I desire a
glass of water you know uh uh or what
about or even we sing songs about a
desire for God you know a hunger for God
so you know desire can't be all bad and
I think that's true so I think maybe we
need to like Nuance this a little bit
where maybe the English is a little
clunky because we just have a one word
desire and it sort of covers everything
you know the good the bad anything in
between uh maybe it's a little clunky
maybe we need like a word
for desire gone awry desire gone off the
rails
uh kind of a Madness that overtakes us
um and I think the word that early
Christians begin to use
um was attachment
and I think that's a really good word
attachment in fact I have this quote
from father um abazastimos Ancient
Ancient Christian and he said for as I
always like to say it's not possessing
something that is harmful
but being
what
patched to it
that's the thing
um and you know what's interesting is
sometimes even in renouncing a
possession
giving it up
saying oh no no I don't do that I won't
purchase that I won't I don't need that
I'm gonna give it away you know what can
still remain
even in the pronunciation of it
weirdly attachment like someone who's
obsessed with the thing they've Left
Behind they think about it all the time
you know are very passionately intense
that everyone know they don't do that
you know you can just tell like
they're kind of eating up like they're
very into that they've Let It Go but
they're like super what
attached and I even think like probably
most of us I think would at least myself
um
probably I'm attached
not even probably I am attached to many
thousands of things more than I would
like to admit I mean because I think we
don't want to be you know shallow
materialistic people or whatever you
know we don't want to use people use
things you're like we don't want to be
like that so I think generally we kind
of distance ourselves like oh yeah yeah
that's the key that's probably that's
the most thing so you know of course I
have all the stuff I'm just not attached
to it you know oh it's cool
it's cool you know and the trick is what
happens when it actually goes the way
you know what I mean like then all of a
sudden you're like oh my gosh like I'm
just imagining like I don't know like uh
retirement fund or something you know
that's like hey you know what
it's money it's the Lord's anyway and
you know like it's fine he'll he'll take
care of us you know and uh you know all
your stock in your company and this
company goes bankrupt and it's all wiped
out and you're like okay I'm gonna go
grieve for about three months you know
like just lost four hundred thousand
dollars or whatever then you know like
oh my gosh right we're
yeah attachment's a really big deal
in fact I go so far as to say maybe it
might just might be sort of underneath
much of our misery
like if you just find yourself like
perpetually always sort of unhappy
um it might be good to ask like huh
what am I attached to
like what's the what's the thing that's
kind of eaten me alive I want to give
you a definition of uh attachment it's
anything finite temporary and unstable
AKA pretty much anything or anyone
except God because any created thing is
of course finite temporary unstable
that I bind here's the key not that I
that I have in my house no but that I
bind my emotional stability and
happiness too
like that that's the key that's when you
know you know when you lose it and you
just sort of like oh poof it's gone well
darn okay you know that's when you can
tell like oh well you weren't very
attached to that it was fine you had it
it was nice and it was gone and you're
okay with that you know
um
but what are those things what are those
experiences what are those people what
are those
dreams what are those goals
that we like kind of get latched on to
you know
and uh
would become obsessed with it
even as in the process it kind of makes
us uh utterly miserable
and it's this is really tricky because
of course attachments are everywhere
we're immersed in a culture that far
from saying you know let go of your
attachments be free you know what is the
culture saying
you know what you need
more attachments like do you find
yourself kind of empty
have I got an attachment for you
like this is every commercial
um
it's problematic I know for many years
like we could
talk of course there's like thousands of
examples almost anything we could be
attached to
um for many years and at some level I
still wrestle
um but uh I really struggle with the
idea of being a success
and uh
I won't ask you to raise your hands but
anyone else
you know
just being like and you know or maybe
even more than that like even more than
being a success it was like maybe it put
in the negative it would be not being a
failure
you're like even more than I wanted the
positive I was just like terrified of
the negative you know like oh Lord I
don't need to end up a billionaire you
know but oh my gosh if the people around
me are like that guy man what an
underachiever you know
um and it plays out like at least in my
own life it played out in like a
thousand different ways um I shared in
my e-letter little story this or two
maybe two weeks ago I went to
um Garland ISD their Natatorium uh and I
thought this was like an administrative
building every time I've driven by it in
a Firewheel like this giant building
says like Garland ISD and uh it's a pool
it's a and our four pools I mean it's
just huge and um I was there because my
daughter uh Eve is a freshman
dear Lord where has time gone and
um so she's trying out for the uh the
sexy high school swim team
and so I walk in the building and the
smell of chlorine
hits my face
and I am flooded with memories
because you see uh I grew up very into
swimming I was into Club swimming which
as you know Club anything
talk about how easy it is for desire to
go awry
obsessive you know you that's that's the
greatest place to see desire gonna ride
go to uh youth sports
and all the parents I mean not just like
the kids but the parents on the
sidelines
you know it's like whoa
attached you know
and at least themselves they could maybe
control like if they were playing the
game at least maybe with some attached
they could try harder you know they
can't even control the person their kid
you know just eats the stuff anyway so
I'm there at uh I walk in flooded with
these memories because
um I I struggled with this so mightily I
like started off loving it I did it for
years I don't know seven eight years and
I started off loving swimming the whole
process the kind of meditative side of
you know so quiet and under the water
like I loved it
um but at some point I just started
getting these like goals
I want to make fade I want to make
junior Nationals I wanted to get a
college scholarship that was sort of how
we all rationalized this ridiculous
amount of energy we were pouring into
this thing it was like well it's it's so
that I can get a college scholarship it
was remarkable to talk to like 11 year
olds who were like I'm trying to get a
college scholarship you know it's just
throwing we were so intense like
swimming's right up there with
gymnastics for like levels of insanity
you know you do like I don't know club
soccer is sort of like three you know or
multiple practices a week you know
someone means like eight practices a
week sometimes two a day it seems just
insane so it ate me alive by the end I
hated it
I hated it I felt like a failure I
wasn't big enough strong enough I didn't
hit my goals I hated it
so I'm sitting there and watching my
daughter swim back and forth and I'm
feeling all the feelings about this like
oh my God I told her afterwards
um before and I've had this conversation
with her like five times now and I I sat
her down and I was like girl
do not make the same mistake I did
like do this because you like it
enjoy it enjoy every lap enjoy your
teammates
enjoy the heck out of it just have a
ball like you know and you know try hard
of course this is something beautiful in
that you know
um
but oh don't don't lose yourself in it
don't know now what was it like what was
the thing that ate me alive attached
attachment like I've lost you know and
isn't this what happens to us like in a
thousand different ways from
relationships to Career stuff you know
to the job we love that we can no longer
do or you know whatever and we're just
like I can't imagine life without that
thing can you hear the attachment in
that right something I've bound my
emotional stability and happiness to or
a relationship right we do this with
relationships like how could I ever live
without that person
yeah yeah I hear you you know the the
challenge is that there can be love in
that right like I really love them but
that's like that's sort of creeping
towards the language of addiction
you know I can't be I'll never be happy
without so and so you know it's like
um
it can start to eat Us Alive
and um perhaps Above All Things what's
really challenging about attachment is
you know when we're in that kind of
attached place
um we can't be content
um we can't be grateful I can't be at
peace
because when I think of um when I think
of like what's the difference between
sort of healthy desire love and
attachment I think of sort of language
like this like if desire kind of the
best sense of the word is sort of gentle
um attachment is um kind of compulsive
and violent remember James language
earlier dragged away
um if desire can use this words like
um prefer
and would love to and hope and wouldn't
that be awesome
attachment uses words like
ought
must have to need to can't be happy if I
don't that's that's when you know you're
getting eaten alive if desire can be
healthily oriented towards God and a
love for others then attachment is like
an unhealthy codependency where I start
to use people and experiences and
substances and things to get my
emotional fix
you know it's weird how we can even be
attached to beliefs and opinions
that's kind of weird isn't it like ideas
like I suppose it's just an idea being
an idea and it's like oh well I think
this other people think that and that's
okay I'm confident what I think but it's
okay all of a sudden you can tell when
you're attached to it when someone like
attacks the idea how defensive do you
get
you know do you find yourself just like
just in a rage
like you're now it's like identity to
attack the thing the idea is to attack
you
you know it's the stability thing or we
do this with organizations we do this
with churches
um of course I hope you love the table
but don't be
attached in a
codependent there will never God could
never have another church for me not
another one in the world you know if the
table would ever go away my spiritual
life would be just sunk you know okay no
God's got you you know
God's got you in fact I was thinking why
do um
like you know there's all often like
scandals and all sorts of organizations
but churches do you know those financial
impropriety or uh you know some that are
indescribe or abused or something that
happened and then what do um what do we
do we like the leaders you know kind of
like hush it up
you know kind of like oh we can't we
can't just be honest about that why not
well attachment
you know which is like we're we're
bonded to it we're bound to it so
powerfully that if that were to struggle
if that were to take a hit if that were
to go away
oh my gosh you know like you can you can
see where this goes now up to this point
this is a lot of bad news I realized
like oh you're really hitting us over
the head of this attachment thing
um what's the good what's the good news
um I think the good news is that Jesus
Christ has a better way in fact it's an
interesting kind of practice to go back
through the gospels and read Jesus words
with a language of attachment and desire
in mind and notice how unattached Jesus
was
like not in a weird way where he was
like cold and distant from everyone I
don't mean that right hopefully you are
catching what I'm saying you know like
he loved people
but also you know it was like
entrusted in the father you know I mean
I think of times even where like people
were like we need you please heal us you
know and he's like I'm sorry I'm spent
that's all I have today goodbye and he
just gets on a boat and sails across the
lake Jenner's like you just left all
those people they needed you you know uh
um or people who didn't like him
you know some of us can't handle that
like people don't like me they don't
approve of me you know Jesus was so um
beautifully unattached and he really
invited us into this like completely new
way of being if I had to choose a word
like what is the unattached life about I
would use the word relax
it's a relaxed life
and and the word free
you're just
free I want to read this is from the
gospel of Matthew chapter 6.
um verse starting verse 26. Jesus said
we'll see if you can kind of hear these
like with new ears so to speak look at
the birds of the air
they don't sew they don't reap they
don't store away in Barns and yet your
heavenly father feeds them
are you not much more valuable than they
can any one of you by worrying at a
single hour to your life and why do you
worry about clothes
see how the flowers of the field grow
they don't labor they don't Spin and yet
I tell you not even Solomon in all his
Splendor was dressed like one of these
if that is how God clothes the grass of
the field which is here today and
tomorrow is thrown into the fire will ye
not much more clothe you oh you of
little faith
can you kind of hear in that poetry
there's like a relaxed way of being in
the world where you just like know hey
I'm gonna be okay
God's Got Me
God loves me I mean what did Jesus say
my yoke is easy my burden is light
does your life feel heavy
do you feel heavy
what are you carrying what are you
attached to
that Jesus is inviting you to do what
Let It Go
Let It Go I think one of the difficult
things about sermons it's often asking
us to do something in this sermon I'm
not asking you to do anything
in fact I want you to do the opposite
this Summer the point of this little
sermon is let
go
let go some of you to flourish you don't
need to like add another spiritual
discipline right what you need to do is
like let go give some things to God to
trust that God's Got You
in the name of the Father the Son in the
Holy Spirit amen
so
as we come to the table of the Lord
tonight
as we take in the body of Christ and the
bread the blood of Christ in the wine we
do so as the people longing for freedom
longing to let go
there's a uh a quote from a spiritual
writer named ajan cha and he says um if
you if you want to have peace or if you
let go a little you will have a little
peace if you let go a lot
you know what
you'll have a lot of faith
if you let go completely
you will have complete peace
and I think that's the invitation as we
come here as you take in the Eucharist
my prayer is that it would be like good
medicine going into you
empowering you healing you letting you
um
Simply Be Who God's created you to be
nothing more nothing less
so the way we'll do this we'll start on
the front row and folks will just form a
center line right here and we'll just
kind of work our way back
we practice what's called an Open Table
I mean if you're here tonight and you
want to participate then you are free to
do that regardless of denominational
affiliation or exact theology or
whatever if you want to connect with the
Risen Christ then you um forward the red
cups are wine the white cups are grape
juice
and um
then finally you can just partake
whenever you'd like so I won't like come
back up and lead you through the through
the partaking you can take immediately
you could return to your sleeper take
however you'd like to do it
so this is the table
not at the church
but of the Lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more so come
you who have much faith
and you who have little
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long
you who have tried to follow
and you who have failed
because it's the Lord Jesus himself who
invites you and it's his will that those
who want to meet him should need him
here
come to the table
[Music]
foreign
we're going to close our time together
tonight with an older song we've done it
a couple times before but it's called
draw me close to you and for me it's
been a song that kind of is a good
barometer for where my desire is with
with them wanting the
um the ways of Jesus wanting the heart
of God
wanting his best instead of my own
and um as Brett was talking I was
thinking you know a great uh challenge I
think for any of us is if you want to
know how attached you are to things move
in with 10 other people
and you will quickly realize how
attached you are to
thinks the way you like to do things
your time you know just
um it can be very revealing for me
and tonight was kind of a good challenge
to reset and realize where where are
those places in my life where I've begun
to hang on a little too tightly you know
to my own ways my own stuff my own
ideals uh
and so anyways I hope that as we join in
this last song together if you want to
stand with us sometimes we just sit
through this last one but I'd really
like us to engage this and if you feel
comfortable just kind of as a posture of
um of opening your hands instead of
grasping so tightly of letting go a
little bit if you want to just open your
hands up before God and sing these words
with us I hope that it's something that
can be a reset for us
[Music]
draw me close to you
Never Let Me Go
[Music]
lay it all down again
hear you say that I'm your friend
[Music]
you are my desire
no one else will do
there's nothing else could take your
place
[Music]
see you're all I want
you're all I want
You're All I've Ever Needed
help me know you
foreign
[Music]
please
you are my desire
foreign
no one else will do
[Music]
there's nothing else could take your
place
to feel the warmth of yours
help me find the way
bring me back to you
[Music]
foreign
I lay it all down again to hear you say
that I'm your friend
getting back to that quote earlier about
prayers just
acknowledgment of Friendship with God
and I was thinking maybe the antidote to
attachment is friendship with God
at me cool so anyways
um
thank you for being here it means so
very much and
um we would love if this is your first
time or second time if you're new here
and we haven't gotten to connect with
you yet we have cards on that same tiny
table in the back that you can fill out
just to give us your information so that
we can reach out Brett will follow up
with you and say hey maybe someone from
our Elder team will reach out but we
just don't want you to slip through the
cracks that's really all that it's about
we don't want to Hound you for anything
um but please take advantage of those
cards and fill out and give us your
information if if you're new and if
you're interested in that welcome to the
table class or you want to hear more
about the table now's the perfect time
it's coming up in two weeks on the 27th
you can sign up there um and um yeah
don't forget to also give us feedback if
you're interested in the workshop for
lgbtq uh allies friends family things
like that so um we invite you at the
close of our service service to complete
the worship experience if you believe in
what we're doing here and you want to be
part of it please consider giving in the
back at the table there's a box there
that you can drop offering in that same
QR code can lead you the one that Josh
has on the screens right now
um that can lead you to our giving but
guys that's really just part of our
worship is we give it all back to God
and say we want to be part of what
you're doing here
um so we invite you to do that there
um you can just sign up for regular
giving if that's something that you
don't want to have to think about it
um and
um yeah just
that's that's there for you so consider
how you want to be a part of that as
well and um in Closing one of our
founding members and one of the members
of our Elder team wrote a benediction
that's especially for us here at the
table Karen Miner wrote these words and
it is my privilege to pray them over you
tonight
um if you would like to open your hands
in a posture of receiving
um I want to speak this over you
that you are a child of God
you are a child of God
and this is true on your best day and it
is especially true on your worst
so as you go into your week ahead with
all of its yet to be determined highs
and lows go with the assurance that you
are loved you are worthy you are
accepted Just As You Are
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same Gifts of
Grace and unconditional love to everyone
you come into contact with
go with God be blessed good night
[Music]
thank you
my desire
s
[Music]
nothing else can take away
feel the warmth of yours
[Music]
bring me back to you
you're always
[Music]
help me
you're wrong
[Music]
go Finley